[Music]
gwen stefani and blake shelton know how
to put on a show together sometimes i
just feel like i'm in a dream the 51
year old singer performed a no doubt
classic while on stage with her hubby
blake
the singer posted a video on her
instagram singing don't speak while the
country star jammed out on his guitar
[Music]
in the clip gwen rocks a white crop top
black distressed shorts an oversized
yellow plaid shirt and orange booties
and she simply captioned the video quote
don't speak blake shelton on guitar
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this will be documented in history
forever
the performance comes a day after gwen
shared photos and video on instagram
from her honeymoon tour with her husband
who performed at bash on the bay a
country music festival in ohio in her
post stefani shared selfies backstage as
well as a video of blake performing for
the crowd
[Music]
but this isn't the first time the couple
has taken the stage together since tying
the knot back in july the newlyweds
dueted at the country crooner's old red
bar in his native oklahoma
they sang their collabs happy anywhere
and nobody but you during the intimate
show
[Music]
[Applause]
gwen and blake got married july 3 at the
country star's oklahoma ranch in a
ceremony officiated by the voice host
carson daly it's one of those once in a
lifetime
you know moments at the time a source
told e.t it was a fairytale experience
even for the guests and that everyone at
the wedding was so thrilled to see gwen
and blake finally get married they have
both been through a lot and deserve to
find each other they were meant to be a
couple in every way
[Music]
you